ضم الينا الان مدير مكتب الجزيره في بغداد
سامر يوسف تفضل
سامر لى المعلومات حتى هذه اللحظه لا يمكن
القول بانها رسميه هي معلومات متداوله على
منصات تابعه لفصائل
عراقيه وايضا على وسائل اعلام عراقيه اخرى
بعض المصادر تنقل من مكان
الحادث الاسم تردد كثيرا اسم القيادي
الساعدي في كتائب حزب الله تردد كثيرا على
انه هو المستهدف المنصات التي تتبع
الفصائل وبالتالي هي تنقل عن مصادر في
الفصائل بطبيعه الحال قالت بان الاستهداف
جاء بطائره مسيره امريكيه هذا ما لم يؤكده
احد حتى هذه اللحظه بشكل رسمي لا مصادر
رسميه ولا حتى بيان رسمي يبدو حتى ان
الولايات الولايات المتحده لم تتبنى حتى
هذه اللحظه هذه العمليه ولكن هناك عمليه
في شرق بغداد استهدفت مركبه مدنيه تقل
ثلاثه
اشخاص ينتمون لفصائل
عراقيه هذا الاسم هو المسؤول بحسب مصادر
اوليه من فصائل عراقيه هو المسؤول عن
الطيران المسير في سوريا والطيران المسير
الذي
استهدف مواقع امريكيه ان صح القول قواعد
امريكيه او معسكرات حتى في سوريا في اي
العراق وبالتالي ربما هذا ما يجعل هذه
التفاصيل اقرب الى الدقه حتى وان لم
تؤكدها مصادر رسميه حتى هذه اللحظه الرد
الامريكي هو المتوقع يتوقع ان تتبنى
الولايات المتحده يتوقع ان يصدر بيان رسمي
بطبيعه الحال من الجهات
والسلطات العسكريه تحديدا الرسميه بهذا
الاتجاه ما هو مؤكد ان كل كل منصات
الفصائل العراقيه كل وسائل الاعلام التي
تتبع الفصائل العراقيه اضافه الى وسائل
اعلام عراقيه اخرى تتبنى نفس المعلومه
تتحدث بنفس الاسماء بنفس التفاصيل من
عمليه الاستهداف في بادئ الامر هناك ثلاثه
ضربات بثلاثه صواريخ وهذا ما نقله شهود
عيان بطبيعه الحال استهدفت موقع الانفجار
الذي يقع في شرق العاصمه العراقيه بغداد
تحديدا في منطقه المشتل هنا كما هو معروف
هو معقل مهم لتواجد الفصائل العراقيه
لقاده هذه الفصائل في تلك المناطق
وبالتالي كل هذه المعلومات التي تتبناها
هذه المنصات يمكن القول بانها تدفع باتجاه
ان تكون المعلومه دقيقه وصحيحه هناك
استهداف بطبيعه الحال ولكن حتى هذه اللحظه
ليلى وبعد مرور قرابه الساعه او اقل من
ساعه ل هذا الاستهداف لم يصدر شيء رسمي
يؤكد كل هذه التفاصيل بشكل رسمي قاطع